[Music]
deadly
it will not change under my watch
get out of my dorm get out hey I'm
warning you do not take another step
toward me
see how they teach the children to treat
their guests
[Applause]
I like it hey hey hey hey who's it down
put it yourself come on it's all right
princess small small girl
I am going to give you two options you
can come to wakanda conscious or
unconscious
you need to be conscious of the way that
you look walking around here all that
Ash on your head
oh it's funny no it's not I told you you
look good
stop right there
who are you and how did you get in here
this place is amazing
the air is pretty
underwater
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave that never have
to change who they were
listened you have to reveal your secret
to the world I am not a woman who enjoys
or repeating herself who are you I had
many names
my people call me
but my enemies call me no more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that can't be good
[Music]
now is our time to strike
told them
Who We Are
black panther wakanda forever really
PG-13 only theaters November 11th get
tickets now
[Music]
only the most broken people
can be great leaders
[Music]
they called him
the feather serpent Court
killing him will risk Eternal War
surface world
you know what you whispered
foreign
[Music]
The Woman No Cry
audiences have embraced wakanda and
black panther
and the chat with he knew exactly what
this story what these images meant to
the world
we all suffered an incredible loss when
we lost Chadwick Chad was very much our
artistic partner I would spend time with
him just he and I talking about like
where we want to see a story go how much
he admired to other characters and the
actors that portrayed them and the
telling of this story we were all able
to honor him together it was really
moving to come back to wakanda and for
us to be able to do it with a sense of
Celebration
there's so much that's happening in this
movie is amazing so many new characters
to explore just seeing the world of
wakanda again and then now we're going
to this whole new world underwater
my enemies
introducing Neymar it was a character
we're really excited to portray in the
film arguably one of the oldest comic
book characters that there is the
opportunity to play a character like
this it's a dream he's the king of an
underwater civilization called talukan
he is regarded as a living God
I need I need now with wakanda is an
ally or an enemy
the level of care creating this story it
is astounding and so it just really felt
like for all of us to give it everything
we have and more I'm just so grateful
and blessed to be a part of this the
actors were filled with emotion and
passion are you Queen I
only it's gone all together we ended up
using those feelings to create something
really special
the action and adventure with the
emotional Stakes so high things are
happening up down and everywhere
I'm so excited about the world being
able to tap into wakanda again
how each character takes on new
challenges and I'm excited about us
honoring Chad
yeah he would want us to just Inspire
the world
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you